hey you guys
what are we talking about today m night
shyamalan
shyamalan yeah well okay well the thing
about m night shyamalan and
you know this has been said by millions
of people not just us
but you know he started out real strong
with the sixth sense yeah which
which is actually a really good movie
that's his movie yeah he
and then after that it seemed like a
little bit of diminishing returns let's
say that
um actually i like his his take on
superhero movies
yeah a lot of people like unbreakable
yeah uh you know
split and what was the other one no i
can't i forgot that whole trilogy
glass that was the third one i actually
want to own all those on blu-ray yeah
see those are good yeah those are good
and his uh
and the very first one is good
i don't really like science i'm gonna
let jenny handle it
i you know what's weird is that i
saw signs i didn't see it in the theater
i did see some of his movies in the
theater i think i saw sixth sense in the
theater i saw the village in the theater
which i didn't love but i didn't hate it
as much as some people did
um but after the village i wasn't really
interested in seeing anything else of
his especially because i heard they were
just complete ass after that especially
like lady in the water the last
airbender stuff like that
but and the happening which is
supposedly like really really
funny but not intentionally you can't
really take people's words for it you
have to see it yourself i mean
that's true people say that it sucks i
saw it so that was pretty good but
but if everybody says it sucks then
it's probably safe to say that it
probably sucks
i don't know everybody said the mummy
sucked so that the other day i liked it
but
i i it was all right i liked it it's a
matter of
time we're gonna talk well actually no
we'll
actually we're recording this this is
going up after that will be
okay so we talked about that we talked
about it already yeah
even though not in real life but right
in in youtube
terms we talked about it writing uh but
yeah but the weird thing about it okay
so i saw signs probably a year or two
after it came out
i didn't i liked it when i saw it i
didn't love it because i'm not you know
i'm not a big alien movie
person um you know what i mean other
with a few notable exceptions
but watching it again i it was a lot
better than i remembered
you know what i'm saying not really
[Laughter]
you didn't like it you don't like it it
got worse the second time for me
really interesting yeah i saw it before
and thought it was okay
but then seeing it again it just it
wasn't rewatchable
and i think it's because
when you see it for the first time you
re you're really uh expecting something
big and impressive to happen something
along the lines like close encounters of
the third kind that never really happens
though
so knowing what it is that they're
dealing with takes all the suspense out
of it takes all the you know all the
wonder out of it you oh yeah it's that
dang running around missing fingers you
know well i would argue that that might
be why
the sixth sense is such a great movie
when you see it for the first time if
you don't know what the twist is
yeah but if you watch it again it's not
you know you know it's not as awesome
because you already know what the twist
is and i think that's like the best
thing about it
yeah bruce willis carries that movie he
does yeah i mean and i will
still argue that that's that's a pretty
great move yeah it's good um but the
thing about signs
that i guess like i said i i saw it
before and it just didn't make that much
of an impression
but i knew a lot of people liked it like
you know particularly in regards to uh m
night shyamalan's movies and we're like
you know this is kind of one of his only
good ones
and so i wanted to revisit it for the
show because i hadn't seen it in such a
long time
i think that what maybe what is
disappointing for people if they don't
know anything about it is that you're
expecting
something like like you said like close
encounters or even like independence day
or something like that it's you know
it's like an alien invasion
but the movie's not really about that
he's really kind of just
using aliens as sort of like a
metaphorical device to talk about other
things
and there's actually a pretty popular um
uh theory going around on the internet
that has been going around for a long
time
that the aliens are not actually aliens
but they're kind of like demons because
this movie
is about faith it's not about aliens
so all right so if you haven't if on the
off chance you haven't seen signs
because i feel like everybody has
probably [ __ ] seen this movie i will
say
that this is one of mel gibson's best
acting performances the acting's great
the acting is actually pretty fantastic
it's actually shot really well
it is yeah yeah the whole cast is great
in it um it's got a fantastic score
yeah the score is really good a lot of
people have uh have
singled that out for praise because it
really is a good score this is not
a [ __ ] movie by any means it's it's a
high quality movie
it's just not really real we're
watchable i don't think
well like you said once you know once
you know what's going on i don't know
but i think i appreciated it more
the second time because since i had
already seen
you know the couple scenes with the
aliens and i already knew that it was
aliens
so i could focus more on the character
drama and like what was going on with
that
so i think i liked it more and you know
what's really weird the first time i saw
it
i did not i totally did not remember it
being funny
but it's funny like intentionally funny
like not not like the happening which
was like so bad that it was funny
it actually has intentional humor in it
that actually really works
and i had forgotten completely forgotten
that aspect of it
um but yeah so all right so basically
you got mel gibson
and he is a uh his name's graham hess
and he is or he used to be an episcopal
priest
uh but he has lost his faith he lost his
faith because his wife
died in this random car accident she
died like in a really really horrible
way
and like um it's weird because i
i know that he must have used because
there's all been all these urban legends
where a dude is at some terribly um
you know perilous job and he gets stuck
in a machine
and he's like all [ __ ] up but like the
top half but he's still conscious and
like the top half of him they always
call his wife to like come and talk to
him like before he dies because they
have to turn the machine back on
so that's like a pretty uh famous urban
legend so i think that
uh m knight kind of used it for this
because the wife gets hit by a car like
pinned against a tree
and she's essentially like torn in half
so they can't move the car but she's
still conscious so they
like have mel gibson come and talk to
her or whatever so that's kind of shown
in flashback throughout the movie so his
wife has died he's not dealing with it
too well
um he's lost his faith he's doesn't
believe in god anymore
and he's raising these two kids um bo
and what's the other kid's name
uh [ __ ] man now i can't remember what
the other kid's name is the other kid's
name is rory culkin
that's her and also the little girl beau
is played by
abigail breslin this was her very first
role
she was in zombieland later on she was
maggie in maggie with
the zombie movie with arnold
schwarzenegger she's been like in a ton
of other movies as well
but yeah this was her first movie and
she is cute as a button in this
usually i don't like child actors but
she's actually pretty cute in joaquin
phoenix
joaquin phoenix plays his the younger
brother who has kind of like moved in
with him to help take care of the kids
or whatever it's hard but it's hard to
believe that this movie is so old that
joaquin phoenix looks real young in this
well i couldn't believe how young mel
gibson looked at it
seems like this movie came out yesterday
it didn't though you can really tell
this is from a hollywood of a guy bygone
era
you can just the score alone gives it
away you don't hear scores like that
anymore
usually just kind of layer in some
generic [ __ ] well it's an old school
yeah uh you know yeah it it feels like
it's going to be close encounters of the
third kind
that if that's what it feels like it's
going to be it's not
but this is almost kind of like i've
seen this compared to like a twilight
zone episode you know and i think that
it's if you like i said if you approach
it from
that uh angle because you're not you
know
even though the aliens are hostile and
even though they
are invading for whatever purpose
you don't really see any of it but in a
way i think that that's kind of like
good because
you don't see a lot of sci-fi movies
that are just kind of set
with one family and like what it would
be like if you lived with that family
you know what i mean you're seeing it
just through their eyes you don't see
like the big global [ __ ] you don't see
you just see like
glimpses of [ __ ] on tv it almost kind of
reminds me like more recently remember
the movie we watched the vast of night
which was kind of like the same thing
where it was like a big alien type of
thing but it was
it was really grounded just like in one
little town and like a couple characters
and i think that's a really good like
economical way of
putting across because like i said i
don't think he's trying to get across
you know it's a global destruction like
by aliens but he's trying to get across
what it would be like you know perhaps
if this really happened if aliens did
show up
and you you know you just lived in this
family and that's what it would be like
if you were there
you know what i mean so i kind of like
that and i also like too
that he doesn't show the aliens very
much
you know i like that a lot of it is sort
of left to your imagination
i guess it's a personal opinion i
thought i
i didn't like it because of that well
it's a different
yeah it's a different kind of movie to
me it felt almost like a stage play
something that should have been done
on performed live you didn't this didn't
really have to be a movie
but you know because it's so dialogue
driven and i'm just not
it is and like i said it's like it's
more like a philosophical
uh movie for sure yeah because like i
said the whole point of the movie
is um you know mel gibson's character
who used to be a priest getting his
faith back
understanding that um that everything
that happens in the movie
is uh not just a coincidence that
everything
had some meaning like his wife dying uh
the weird thing that his
daughter has with the water like where
she thinks water's contaminated so she
leaves glasses of water all over the
house
um the stuff about uh the kid the sun
having
asthma uh the thing about joaquin
phoenix's character his name is merrell
about him being kind of like a failed
baseball player and still having the bat
you know and all this other kind of
stuff
because all that stuff plays into it
later so it's almost kind of like
that the whole thing and you can say
um that it's contrived you can say that
it's on the nose
which it is um you know from a
storytelling standpoint nobody ever said
that m knight was a great
writer you know what i'm saying well
he's got a point he's trying to get
across
so he does it that way yeah and i mean
it can be like a little heavy-handed but
i think
that it worked in this situation
the movie is a product of its time sure
you know um
man had i if i was a little younger
maybe i would enjoy it but i'm just
getting i'm just kind of jaded
i'm not really big into when it comes to
cinema i i don't really need dialogue or
story driven
um movies that much you know i mean i
i'm really into visual aspects
visual storytelling um you know
something along the lines of you know
apocalypse now or conan or something you
know looking where
there's more showing you stuff than
there is talking about it
but jenny's a writer so you know she
sees things through that framework of
what what you can do with writing and
dialogue
that's great some people like that to me
i just kind of
it becomes tedious for me i'm just kind
of disinterested in it you know i
thought this movie was boring
on second viewing on the first viewing
i think i thought it was a lot better
because i didn't really know what was
going to happen
i thought it was going to end up with
like a bigger deal in the end and it's
not really
it's just i don't know it's a matter of
opinion i didn't really like this move
well like i said it kind of depends on
how you're coming at it if you're coming
at it like expecting
and you know and i'm not even saying i
don't think this is a great movie
but watching it again i liked it better
the second time
that i liked it the first time i think
the first time it didn't make that much
of an impression
i liked the couple alien scenes like i
really love that
that famous jump scare like with joaquin
phoenix watching the
the brazilian kids birthday party like
on the tv and like
move children vominos you know what i
mean and then like the [ __ ] uh
the alien walking by so i thought that
was like really well done i also like
too that there are a couple jump scares
in this but they don't but he doesn't
telegraph them
which you know what i mean it's not that
music like oh everything goes quiet and
then blah
like you know what i mean like uh you
know when the alien is in that's stuck
in the pantry like in his fingers just
come out they don't
he doesn't do like a musical sting or
anything like that which i think makes
it more effective
he's good at building up suspense in
this
and like i said obviously if you've seen
it before you know maybe a lot of the
suspense is lost because you know it's
aliens and you know what the aliens
look like but if you're kind of like i
was trying to watch it from
a point of view of someone that hadn't
seen it before
so the way that he did the shots the way
this particularly that one shot where
mel gibson's like in the corn field
because he heard something out there and
like you know he just sees the little
bit of a leg
so i thought that was kind of cool that
he went such a long time without showing
the alien
um and i also like too that he when he
did show the aliens near the end he
usually showed them in like reflections
like he's like
a reflection of a knife or a reflection
of a tv or something like that i don't
know i just really liked that
choice because like i said i think it's
creepier if you can't really
see it like you know what i mean if you
don't really get yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah i'm just
i'm just trying to compare this to
other movies that are out there you know
what i mean it just
for me friendly alien movies
that still has a lot of suspense a lot
of excitement it's just
very very hard to beat close encounters
the third kind well yeah that's good
movies sure especially uh
the uh the redone ones where they kind
of allowed you to see what was
happening inside the alien craft which
some people don't like that i like
either version of that movie
you know the updated versions i still
liked it um when it comes to uh
attacking aliens
i gotta get i'm gonna give it to tom
cruise's war of the worlds
a lot of people didn't like that movie i
thought it was kind of dumb that they
came out of the ground
but who gives a [ __ ] it's just it's just
bad aliens zapping the [ __ ] out of
people turning them into dust
i liked that one i you know what i
didn't hate it
i liked it i liked that better than say
independence day
yeah i'm not a big fan of independence
you know i'd have to see it again i
think i saw in the theater when it came
out and i maybe saw it once more after
that
and i just i didn't hate it it was just
kind of like meh yeah
i'm not a big fan generally i'm not a
big fan of like these big [ __ ]
spectacle movies you know what i mean um
you know they're fine
but they don't usually make much of an
impression on me you know what i'm
saying
um i kind of like i don't know i i just
kind of like smaller movies i just
i don't know i feel like if something is
too
big or so you can't really like relate
to it or you can't
get a grip on it well i liked the
spectacle movies of the 80s and the 90s
and the 70s
yeah i mean when the 2000s started to
roll around there it started to be some
diminishing returns there
nowadays the 2020s late 2000 teens
no they were [ __ ] bad most of them
well because and we've talked about this
before
because spectacle now that we have cgi
yeah
they can show anything yeah so
essentially there's no sense of wonder
anymore because everyone's just kind of
like oh the more of that
more cg yeah thank you
yes i got this video game at home yeah
so that's what i mean so
so in a way going back to signs i think
that's why that works
why it works better on this one because
it's not it's an alien invasion movie
but one where the alien invasion isn't
really the
most important or the theme of the movie
which is more like uh character driven
but also i like that it just it grounded
it in one family it grounded it in
you know if you were in this house this
is what you would see
you know what i'm saying now let's talk
a little bit about because i know a lot
of people
even people who like this movie complain
about
um oh my god why would the aliens if
they were intelligent enough to have
like interstellar travel why would they
come to a planet it was 70
water if they were uh hurt by water
now i i get that um
but i will give you and i'm not saying
that's not like a fantastic
it's not like a fantastic uh
screenwriting decision but chances of
life being hurt by water
yeah well yeah well here's the thing
though
i i'll give you i'll give you two
arguments like i said if you if you
think that it's like i'm not gonna argue
with you about that okay it's like i
would have come up with something else
if i was writing this movie
but you know but i will say that uh
it was the original uh was it the
original war of the worlds right where
um
microbes got them where microbes got
them where they came there and like you
know
so it was just like regular like [ __ ]
germs or whatever they got them
okay so that was kind of like a mundane
thing that killed the
aliens that you'd think that they would
have known about beforehand
um also another thing is that one like i
said this isn't
very two rather this isn't really an
alien movie it's kind of about and if
you go with the theory that the aliens
are actually demons
then you could argue that the water is
like representative of holy water you
know what i mean and that's what hurts
them
also the aliens weren't here that long
i think that somebody said like um there
was some dialogue
in the movie where somebody on the radio
says you know they didn't come here for
the planet
they came here to harvest the humans
so if they were coming to harvest the
humans then maybe they didn't really
you know uh vet the planet all that much
because they said hey there's like some
human things over there that maybe we
could eat them or whatever
and then they just popped over there and
then they were like oh [ __ ] bro
because they like i said they were only
here for like i think in the timeline of
the movie they're only here for like two
or three days
because they land then they kind of like
you know they're like
start harvesting humans with their
poison gas or whatever and then they
start getting wet and they're just like
[ __ ] me and then they get on their [ __ ]
and they leave
yeah let me come to the defense of uh
war of the
he gave worlds though out with the
microbes yes
all right what's what was mentioned
several times in the book and i and you
most movies mention it
h.g wells's martians were inside their
little mechanical tripods walking around
and the tentacles with tentacles were
grabbing people and throwing them into
baskets
yeah then they were taking the people
and bringing them inside the uh
inside the little tripod machine the war
machine is what they called it
and we're draining them of blood and
injecting that blood into their veins
as food yeah so
microbes kill them maybe not from the
environment but maybe from some kind of
a disease that humans carried that they
they didn't know that they didn't real
realize yeah some kind of virus must
have gone
because i do feel like m night was kind
of making an homage
to that yeah but in a way that was like
a lot more obvious and like i said i'm
i'm going with the thing that he was
doing like a holy one
holy water spiritual [ __ ] sure because
but like i said the whole point of the
movie is
mel gets his faith back that's the theme
any alien that can walk around
this planet without a spacesuit or
pressure suit or anything like that
evolved on a planet that had water well
yeah because there's water in the
atmosphere water atmosphere
you know and everybody's like what if it
rained what if well not only that it's
just that life is gonna be on a planet
like this
if they can be on a planet like this
then it's something based in water
you're not talking about
a mar uh uh you know a moon like titan
where the the liquid is damn frozen
hydrogen or something you know liquid
hydrogen
you know life could evolve in that but
that thing will never walk around
on in the earth's atmosphere yeah you
know the temperature's too high
yeah so it would have evolved on a
planet like this which meant based in
water
yeah so he's got to be talking about
holy water that's kind of like
and like i said i don't think it doesn't
bother me that much because i know a lot
of people were like what the [ __ ] that's
so dumb
but um you know and i get that i get
that
but i just think it's i think it's a
metaphorical movie now i'm not saying
that m knight can get away with that
every single time
because some of the movies that he made
that were dumb as hell
and then later like when people call him
out on it and then he's like well it's
not supposed to be real it's supposed to
be like
a person telling a story or so you can't
get away with that forever
it's also made during a different time
that's true the planetary surveys
weren't
completed and a lot of people even today
don't realize
what the planetary surveys say now based
on what
everything that they've been able to see
on these other stars planets like
venus mars and earth are common most
stars have
planets like this in them yeah we got so
you're going to have to see
all over the place yeah and you're going
to find out they're going to find out
that [ __ ] life is [ __ ] common
real common well i'm sure it is most of
it's probably microbes but
his life's [ __ ] gonna be everywhere
everywhere it can grow that's gonna be
growing there
and it's mostly gonna be like this and
our solar system is a good example of
the average
of what's out there you know gas giants
with a bunch of pros and moons
a couple of terrestrial type planets and
venus falls into that
venus is terrestrial yeah you know uh
that might be habitable one day
yeah it's just the atmosphere the
atmosphere that
people worried about terraforming mars
mars is too small you can't hold an
atmosphere there
be so much easier to terraform venus
really
if you could get rid of that if you
because that's almost the same size
yeah and it wouldn't be that much hotter
if it had
uh um if it didn't have the greenhouse
effect that it has but if you could
add a bunch of water to it you could get
rid of that greenhouse yeah
yeah there's a lot there you could live
on venus if you could change the
atmosphere
wouldn't be that much hotter maybe
that'll be the next generation of uh
sci-fi movies we'll be terraforming
venus and everybody will live in there
but uh yeah well speaking of aliens i
will say that i really really like
i like in this movie that he made the
decision to
do actual crop circles instead of doing
cgi crop circles yeah so all the crop
circles you see they actually made those
yeah they look good too which yeah
obviously and they're obviously real so
it makes that a like a lot better
this movie i didn't realize this movie
cost 72 million dollars to make
do you know how much money this [ __ ]
ship made how much 408 million dollars
plenty of money
yeah it made [ __ ] tons of money it was
super that's why they kept giving him
money to make more movies
even though a lot of people said that
this is probably like his last best one
because when did unbreakable come out
i don't know was it the year or two
before this now i can't remember i don't
remember i don't have a really good
sense of when that was i can't remember
when that came out it's in the 2000s
sometime
well this was 2002 maybe people came out
after this because
yeah unbreakable was pretty it was
decent and um you know even the other
ones now there's a couple like i said
there's a couple of them i haven't seen
i haven't
bothered to watch the last airbender
because everybody
everybody that i talked to said it's
just like don't waste your time because
it's terrible
um i kind of want i i admit i kind of
want to see a lady in the water just
because i heard that it was
so bad i think i did see it i don't
think it i don't even think it stuck
with me
and i kind of want to watch the
happening because i've seen some clips
from it and it looks unintentionally
hilarious
which i'm always down for that but yeah
i mean
you know you have to think m knight at
some point you know he
his movies were making a [ __ ] ton of
money so they kept giving him more money
yeah um i will say too that he's okay so
he's in this movie
too yeah which um he's he's got a little
bit of an ego
let's put it that way um i kind of feel
like
he writes himself into his stories and
then
he's like i think maybe was it lady in
the water where he wrote himself into
the story as a storyteller and his story
ended up like was gonna save the world
or something and i'm just like
arrogant much okay but um yeah indian
spiritualism
i don't know man like a guru but he's
but he's in this
and i think a lot of like i i kind of
like that he'd made the decision
to write himself as the character that
unintentionally killed
mel gibson's wife in the movie like you
know he fell asleep at the wheel and
like hit her
um and i think a lot of people have
criticized his acting in this but it
didn't bother me it didn't stand out as
being bad
actually all the acting in this was fine
and actually mel gibson in this i
thought was fantastic
yeah and uh you know some of the scenes
like emotional scenes like toward the
end where they think the world is ending
and he's talking to his kids and stuff
like that and he was all like his
jaw was trembling and he was tearing up
and stuff i was like damn mel
i had forgotten that how good he was in
this one and like i said i like a lot of
the humor in it too especially like him
and joaquin phoenix like playing off
each other i love the scene where he
comes where mel gibson comes into the
house and
joaquin phoenix and the two kids have
tin foil hats on yeah
you know i mean they're just looking i'm
like what
in case i forget from getting like the
our minds read by the aliens
i would have liked to have seen some
alien technology i'd like to see
some maybe some more alien stuff a
little bit more of a backstory about
what they were trying to do
you're not going to get any of that so
yeah it's
this is essentially like a mystery drama
yeah
and as i said it's more about the
characters and their
psychological journeys than it is about
the aliens the aliens are almost kind of
like incidental or it's almost kind of
like a metaphor
for something else m night's best stuff
was that uh stuff was his version of
superheroes
those three movies right there were
great i would have liked to have seen
a whole universe of those like like the
mcu
a whole universe of mlight shaman's
version of those [ __ ] heroes and
villains
that would have been great i think he
was kind of gearing toward that because
they made three of them and
like i kind of feel like i'd like to see
a whole bunch of those but i don't know
if they made enough
take on a superhero so you guys haven't
seen that see that
they're just regular people that happen
to have
super powers uh it's it's difficult to
explain you gotta start what's the first
one glass
unbreakable unbreakable and then split
split this is the second one and then um
with a glass it's going to hurt yeah we
saw that one unbreakable see unbreakable
yeah that's a real good one because uh
you know they can
the movie is saying that comic books are
based on reality on real human
archetypes and that those kind of people
are out there
and uh when you find them they're not
wearing you know
tights and leotards and they're not
really flying or anything they
it looks like it's within damn near
human abilities but not quite like
knowing what somebody's thinking are
gonna do if you touch them or have you
know what i mean like
one of the heroes could do that uh
there's super villains and [ __ ]
with multiple personalities it's just a
really good idea
and he was his writing for that was just
spot on he nailed it
i was getting pulled into that world i
want all three of those movies
yeah you should probably get yeah i
should get those i was getting it
you could he could have kept me going
forever with those
i mean we just saw glass when it came
out in the theater i haven't seen
unbreakable for [ __ ] years i can't
even remember
another one that i wanted to see was
like the horror version
of superheroes like that bright burn
bright burn was good the evil superman
yeah i dug that yeah it was it's like a
horror i feel like it kind of got mixed
reviews but
i saw a lot of people dug it too yeah i
didn't know what they were i thought it
was a good idea
[ __ ] right like you superhero movies
are possible what if they were [ __ ]
bad and it was a horror movie like hell
yeah
that's a that's another interesting take
a horror movie version of [ __ ]
spider-man a horror version movie of
superman
a horror version of batman yeah yeah
breitbart was kind of like evil superman
evil superman
yeah he was [ __ ] as a little kid he
was trying to rape women and stuff and
doing
he was bad yeah he was a terrible
terrible killed his mama
he was an alien creature destroying
whole cities
kind of like laying the waste well you
know except yeah
we used to have godzilla movies and [ __ ]
this is just he's a human size the size
of a kid
[ __ ] right i was impressed it kind of
disturbed me because i was like going
yeah what if and at the end of that
breitbart movie
they show a news report that something
bad was happening somewhere else like
another one had arrived
yeah another super villain had arrived
some weird [ __ ] yeah i don't know if
that made enough money to like because i
feel like
well i feel like every every big kind of
studio film that comes out now they're
all trying to like make an expanded
universe out of it yeah
which uh or or at least make you know a
series of sequels which i get that
because you know they're
they started gearing that [ __ ] towards
netflix and streaming services
yeah yeah i feel like they're kind of
doing that now but uh but yeah
so yeah signs 2002
yeah i'm gonna say no it's weird because
you the reason that i picked this one to
put in the
poll was because i remember you said you
had seen it and you liked it
but then when you watched it the second
time you didn't like it it's weird
because i liked it better the second
time
i guess because like i said one i had
forgotten how funny it was
uh because actually it is really funny
and the kids are actually funny too like
some of the [ __ ] they say
and um and not in an annoying way the
kids are actually pretty good in this
and uh i forgot how funny it was and i
forgot how
um maybe it's in my mental state at the
time i don't know maybe
like i said i was i remembered that it
was kind of it's almost kind of like a
sci-fi that's not a sci-fi you know what
i mean or like a horizon
it's like a lot of things and not a
thing
[Laughter]
there's another shirt right there it's a
lot of it's like a lot of things but not
a thing
yeah yeah in the way that something like
frailty
is kind of like a demon movie but not or
like a religious movie but not
this is almost kind of like a religious
movie with
you know incidental aliens you know what
i'm saying yeah
so you know but yeah um if you haven't
seen it or if you haven't seen in a long
time and you want to check it out i'd be
interested to know
people that saw it a long time ago and
haven't seen it for many years i want to
know if you had the same experience that
i had
like i said i didn't love it but i liked
it better
the second time because i had only seen
it one other time and that was like ages
and ages ago probably like
15 20 years ago i don't think it held up
and i liked it better the second time
just i guess maybe because i was paying
more attention
yeah because i already knew that it was
amazing it didn't hold up to me i paid
less attention to it the second time
seeing it it's just
okay we'll see because i'm different the
second time i saw it was just more
boring
yeah like it is definitely just a drama
it's not really it's got sci-fi elements
but it's definitely a drama with sci-fi
and talking and talking
tom doesn't have time to listen to all
of that [ __ ] he doesn't have time to
listen to me
had a good score though i really do like
that score actually
and like i said that is that's been uh
kind of called out on a lot of occasions
for being a really good scorer i can't
i can't remember who the [ __ ] did it uh
i'm sure it's on here somewhere but i
can't in my notes but i can't find it
but yeah uh this is actually on 2b
right now yeah i think it's on 2b for
free if you want to watch it might also
be on amazon prime i'm sure it is
i think on amazon prime you might have
to like pay 3.99 but i think it's free
on 2b
so go check it out if you haven't seen
it in a while like i said i'm interested
to see
what everyone's opinion of this is
because i feel like this one is a little
bit divisive
so i want to see like see some
discussion alright so that'll do it for
this movie retrospective
we'll see you guys on the next one bye
you